what we're doing is trying to take
mutations in different genes and combine
them together to understand how genes
work together to coordinate cell life
and we do this in a simple organism like
yeast that only has six thousand genes
but remarkably we yeast is very similar
to humans so it provides a very good
model to understand so what we learn in
yeast can provide us with some direction
or a reference to understand to help us
understand how genes work together to
modulate essential functions and life in
human cells so what we do is take a
collection of yeast strains each of
which is deleted for a different gene or
mutated for a different gene and we use
a technology we developed in our lab
that allows us to combine pairs of
mutations in the same cell and then we
can simply ask do mutations in these
pairs of genes allow the cell to live or
not and we apply we use robotic
technologies to do this and we were able
to test all 18 million possible mutant
combinations and we don't think that
genes work in isolation so there are
obviously many examples of dizzy
Mendelian diseases where a single
mutation in a single gene results in a
disease so those cases would be highly
predictive we think that many common
diseases are affected by combinations of
mutations rare mutations in different
genes what we've done is tested all
possible double mutant combinations to
build this large Network and we see many
structures in these networks that we
think could provide a reference from
which we can start to learn the rules
and principles that might help us to
understand or simplify the problem in
humans and help us understand how
develop rules how different genes
interact we believe that this will help
us simplify the problem or at least
provide a guide to start to understand
how genes work together to modify
complex disease in humans